okay dude
oh no this is what we were talking about
that was amazing his setup was perfect
i'm lim cuban i do speed runs of breath
of the wild
since 2019 which was kind of like the
peak of new glitches being discovered
and i kind of helped shape the game in
that time
i'm a router traditionally so i
basically
use those new mechanics in order to make
new speed runs happen and i still do it
actively to this day and i'm here today
to
react to some interesting new breath of
the wild clips and my name is max also
known as ren harasaki
i've been playing this game since late
2017. one of the first combat guys
uh not the best anymore obviously but uh
i've been in the game for quite a while
now and specialize in combat techniques
so here we go
[Music]
shrine item it looks like it's so fun
that was clean yeah that's an alford
clip i'm pretty sure
like if i see it it looks like this i
haven't actually seen this run but
alford is one of the craziest like
cleanest runs i've ever seen
and this is in my opinion the
uh worst shrine casually so being able
to skip this
uh nicely is pretty cool it's the z
castle shrine which is at the uh
south a color stable and usually you
play this like motion control puzzle
with like a three orbs that you have to
get in each
of the correct like alcoves it's horrid
um i think casually at least i remember
i struggled a lot with it
those are always super satisfying to
watch i don't know why just like doing
something like two seconds is so
so cool i feel like as well like after
doing ielts myself
it's also um it looks really cool but
after
like behind all of these ielts uh like a
thousand clips where it didn't work like
that's always something that you have to
think about how much work actually takes
to get these
it's pretty cool again uh an il stands
for individual level
so these are uh these are shrine speed
runs that
are on their own they don't have
anything to do with like a whole speed
run process it's just
one shrine run that's it individual
level that's what it stands for
okay now we're fighting ah i know this
guy's name is paper
okay
speeds
damn doesn't clean beams so there's a a
couple weird things going on here uh
let's go back to like like right there
so what's going on here is
usually when there's like a pack of
zoflos surrounding you you'll have a lot
of let's also say one usually one or two
at a time like come to attack you
and the zolfo's head hitbox leans really
far forward
so as he was aiming at this others also
thousands came behind him and his head
hitbox actually went into the arrow that
he was shooting it and
launched him backwards which is really
cool so like yeah i see it at that point
so it's really cool to kind of sing
tricks with lazalfo's head hitboxes you
know like
standing below them and they won't see
you because their head hitbox
doesn't reach below it doesn't make any
sense sometimes
also i really actually like and this is
just a small detail
most of these like combat montage
players you included and others have
like their
signature outfits and one thing i like
about this combo specifically actually
i really have i've noticed this from
master saw speedruns i like the combo of
like the
shield of mind's eye and the master
sword we can because they kind of like
overlap
each other when it's like on his back
like here looks like a like a bigger
weapon it's pretty cool yeah the mind's
eye is actually a pretty small
shield so it does like get like show a
lot of the extra features behind links
so it does look pretty cool actually
it's a pretty nice combo
[Music]
okay dude oh no
this is what we were talking about that
was amazing the setup was perfect
so it it seemed pretty i don't know
simple until
it reached the end when i was doing a
speed run about feeding dogs
dog percent and you have to get a lot of
these chests and there's actually
mechanic in the game but if you use
motion controls while your magnesius and
chest and like flick up
that's how you get the chest out like
faster and i think that's what they did
there to launch both of them up so i
feel that part was intentional
i don't think the next part was
intentional yeah actually
um that is a trick for pulling the chest
out while you're not on it but this
specifically is called a magnesius chest
launch
so if you're basically standing on the
the chest that's buried
and you magnesius it and your feet are
actually on it
it will immediately take you out of
magnesium and launch you upwards like
immediately
um without you pushing anything so uh
this sets up for really cool combos
because you can like shoot the chest
with magnesius while you're in the air
with like thunder arrows you can do like
a whole bunch of like damage like that
but i've never seen it to launch an
enemy as well at the same time
which is insane um and the fact that
because of mccobbin wasn't ragdoll
during this then like flailing around he
was actually in a standing position in a
standing state while he was
up in the air so he just shot him out of
the air
yeah which was insane that the coleman
was actually recording for his
combat montage there
no bullet time
[Music]
wait i'm actually surprised that i
haven't seen this
it actually stayed on it for a long time
i don't know the exact name for it
cleric
has looked into it a lot more it's
basically just like turning a guardian
and a boat into a spaceship
and what you do is you cut off all the
guardians legs
and you it's easiest at this location
here because you can use cryonis to kind
of basically flip and push the the
guardian onto a boat
once they do it for just some odd reason
i don't know why
uh the game just freaks out and
levitates
the guardian on its own um
i it has something to do with the legs
not being present and it being on
something else
but again i have no explanation for it
um it's basically just
called a spaceship and you can ride with
the guardian if you want upwards and
it'll just go for a long time
it's actually pretty hard to do because
it's really uncontrollable and sometimes
it'll just spiral out of control and
like flip out
and like just randomly zoom out in
nowhere for this it looks like he was
trying to set it up but you
had other ideas and the guardian just
started to take off on his own
let's look at this one that's something
i am actually already found this week
and i wanted to show you um okay it's an
another interesting idea
you know what i've seen this one already
too i have seen this one okay so um
with my limited speed run knowledge i'm
gonna guess
what okay yeah as a mini game you're
gonna guess what happened and then
you're gonna correct me
so i'm gonna say first that this was
first a horse slide to get to the door
um this must have been a specific horse
slide to get in that direction towards
the
front door and then as soon as he got
there he did
an extended shield clip but that was
very very like i'm it almost looks like
he got the skew
on the way to the door and then he
clipped through the wall like this was
a ton of inputs i i don't think he got
the skew
there i think it must have been one
that's stronger because you can see i've
actually like tilled
pretty heavily oh it's right yeah um
so i think the skew he did already have
but like it is a horse slide which is
really cool for shrines so basically you
set up like a horse light in a specific
direction
there's only very few shrines where it
is being used but that's you can
basically this is one of the coolest
visuals here
as you basically see link already zoom
out of the elevator
so uh for for people who aren't really
knowledged
with with the two glitches can you
explain sort of what's going on
yeah so basically um a horse light is
something you set
up in the overworld you don't actually
set it up in a shrine
so basically start a momentum going into
the load zone
of the shrine then you start the slide
[Music]
and an extended shield clip is something
that
it's also used in speed runs there's
normal clipping which is done all over
the any percent speed run you clip into
the shrine walls to skip the activation
of the tower
an extended shield clip makes the entire
thing a little bit harder it actually
gets frame perfect you have to
re-equip your shield on a perfect frame
and then basically do a
shield jump mid shield jump that way you
are allowed to clip through
thicker doors maybe some runners you can
catch doing that
at the cryoness train you can actually
clip through the door instead of to the
sides that's what sweet ones always used
to do but nowadays people actually
even clip through the door and that's an
esc extended shield clip
makes it frame perfect and the one thing
that's tough about this the d-pad menu
in the game isn't quite perfect so it's
actually not 100 consistent because you
can't even
like pause frame perfectly it's
literally impossible like the game
doesn't let you
so it's a bit tricky but uh once again
an ill usually takes many many attempts
and when it works out it looks like this
got some lighting action that always
looks so cool
but this is the cool club
okay so there's a there's a couple
things going on here so he's basically
uh he's timing all this process
while there's thunderstorm going on and
the thunderstorm strikes like once a
minute i think or something like that
and so he's he's got to do this a couple
times to make this work this is not
easy to do so when a lionel is stuck on
an object um
usually like this goo or some other
object sometimes like herbs and stuff
it'll attempt to jump up in the air and
attack you that that's the way it's just
getting out
um so to to force the lionel into the
position
during the thunderstorm during the
specific time is not easy to do it's
it's he must have taken a long time to
do this so he plays the square bomb
ahead of time he staces the line also
then as soon as the lynel stasis he
shield block resets so
uh shield block reset is basically a
technique where you
explode the bomb and you jump into the
bomb's explosion um with the shield
and it'll knock you into the air and get
you a double jump basically so he stasis
the lynel he
did a shield block reset to get into the
air and it goes immediately into a
thunderclap brush
and what's cool about this obviously is
he's got
time all sorts of thunder effects is
going on stuff like that so
to get this this the stasis to get the
shield block creases to get the thunder
to get the lynel in that position to get
that jump that's
there's so this looks very cool
obviously from this point of perspective
but as a content creator
knowing this clip must have taken
forever to get because the inputs are
already obviously hard to do and then
you have to work with the game because
that lightning strike like you said it's
not like
you can't control it obviously um like
in his case it must have been because
the lionel wields
a metal weapon that actually struck him
or it even that is that even what
happens oh is he
so i yeah i i i've seen axk do this and
i i need to play around with the thunder
mechanics more but
um there's definitely some mechanic
between slow down
and stasis and thunderstorms where uh
you can make the thunder strike the city
the stasis enemy and not yourself
because obviously he had a master sword
so he had
if he was just standing out and about
like this he would have gotten struck by
lightning yeah but instead the lino got
struck instead
and you can actually see that at the
beginning of the clip the light is
the lightning is like targeting him but
then as soon as he's actually
uh starting to shoot with the bow um
that's when it jumps over to the liner
like after the first shot
there's new hidden mechanics for every
player and that's the cool thing about
breath of the wild is there's always
something new for everybody there's
no ending to this game there's always
something new that you can learn it's
incredible
like even the smallest facts like
someday you will discover that when you
open your menu at a cooking pot it will
bring up your materials instead of the
menu you had previously opened
like small effects like that that's like
something you uncover after like two
years
interesting you know again i learned
something new today too
thanks for watching if you like this
format and want to see more then let us
know in the comments below
and if you want to see my solo react
videos or my breakdowns for breath of
the wild
then check out the links in the
description below and make sure if you
want to stay up to date for anything
breath of the wild
stay tuned right here on gamespot
[Music]
wow okay uh
without okay you got me